hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts compassion fatigue
education and engagement in animal
research and presented by Marianne s
felt a veterinary resident at University
of Michigan I'm Suzy Valdez bobrucz and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth and sponsored by Lotte for
more information about our sponsor visit
w-w-w te org before we begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the lower left
of your screen and type your questions
into the drop-down box that appear on
that screen well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if your trouble
hearing or seeing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located on the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen or just use
that ask a question box and let us know
you're having a problem the presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits click on
the accreditation button located on the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen without further ado
please join me in welcoming our
presenter today Marion s belt I will now
turn the presentation over to her
welcome thank you good day and thank all
of you for choosing to virtually
attempted to talk of mine today
so as Suzy said I'm a veterinary
resident at the University of Michigan
and today I want to talk about a topic
that's a really great interest to me I
became aware of the concept of
compassion fatigue when I was a
veterinary student and take
elective course in Greece and pet loss
but it really resonated with me and how
this also is regards to not just private
practice veterinarians but in our field
of laboratory animal science and this
has been a topic of conversation that's
been more and more over the years
getting kind of a hot topic per se in
our field there's been some webinars and
articles on the subject coming out so I
think this is all something that I'm
glad everyone's starting to discuss more
and more so today I am going to be
discussing what compassion peak is and
how we can recognize it who's at risk
and why we should care about it and then
what can we do about it including some
you know ideas about educating people in
our field about it some strategies for
combating it so first let's define the
term it Sebastien Teague is an emotional
and physical burden that's created by
the trauma of helping others in distress
which then leads to reduce capacity for
empathy towards suffering in the future
and a term that's also been applied to
it is the cost of caring and that was
coined by dr. Charles figley who's a
researcher in the field of trauma
ecology in psychology and he was one of
the first researchers to define this
idea and it's associated with specific
professions ones that provide care to
living creatures so that would be human
and veterinary health care mental health
care workers social workers of course
also animal research so the connections
that we form with those that were taken
care of and repetitive and Pathak
responses to them can cause us to kind
of burn out emotionally and this makes
us makes us unable or more difficult to
deal with stresses in our lives both
inside and outside of work and the most
insidious aspect of compassion of T I
think is that it really attacks the core
of what brings people into these fields
which is their empathy and compassion
towards animals
a human there's a couple other terms
that you may find in the literature
surrounding this topic so I wanted to
bring them up I'm here secondary
traumatic stress is exposure to
knowledge about a traumatizing event
that's experienced by another's so it's
pretty enacted
description of compassionate ich so what
they found over time is that family
members and counselors and people that
provide care to those that so to
traumatize individuals will actually
start showing similar signs to the
actual traumatized individuals
themselves and then this was described
as secondary traumatic stress and dr.
Charles figley later described it as
compassion fatigue as well and so these
terms are kind of interchangeable and
you might also see vicarious trauma and
secondary victimization in the
literature as well now some of you may
have also heard the term burnout and
it's sometimes used in relation to
compassion fatigue but I do want to
point out that it is different any
person in any career can experience
burnout it's really defined as what
occurs in when a person is experiencing
too much stress or pressure and gets to
uses few sources of satisfaction in
their work environment so it's really
related to kind of external work
environment so things like your salary
and how much you get paid and how far
away up to travel and you know vacation
time so it's especially a problem if
somebody is stressed at work but they
don't feel a sense of appreciation for
what they're doing as well so burnout
can be treated by changing your
environment so getting a new job in a
new environment can actually solve it
but if someone's experiencing compassion
fatigue and they get a new job it's not
going to fix the problem so compassion
fatigue is associated with the specific
work that we do so so the head leaving
is not going to fix the problem but
since burnout does definitely contribute
to compassion fatigue and some
definitions actually state that
compassion fatigue is a combination of
secondary traumatic stress and burnout
together you can
some short-term benefits from changing
jobs but if you're staying the same
field still working with animals provide
care to animals you can continue to have
the same problems in a new work
environment now only that I like the
same productive master tango like this
analogy that it's our emotional
resources and compassion are like a bank
so if we keep making withdrawals without
into deposits soon we're going to be
empty and it affects your job your
personal professional relationships and
even your physical health
so if compassion fatigue is the cost of
caring then what maybe is the payment
there's a term that's used called
compassion satisfaction and this is when
people feel really invigorated and happy
by the work that they do they feel
successful so if you're drawing out of
your emotional bank constantly but you
can find ways to fill it again then you
can potentially improve your compassion
fatigue signs and you'll stop feeling
such a harsh effects of cash fatigue so
as we continue to talk about ways to
combat this we'll be touching on
basically ways that we improve our
compassion satisfaction now since our
job in this field does usually require
caring for animals and of course the
answer to this problem is to not not
feel compassion at all how do we
overcome this so I think the first step
is really kind of what I'm doing right
now is educating those in our field
about it and bringing awareness to the
issue in our industry I think it's been
pretty common to not discuss the
emotional aspects of our jobs and not
talk about the potential emotional
trauma this can cause so bringing
awareness to the idea that is normal and
it's okay it's really important and then
that you need to learn coping strategies
which can include self-care techniques
positive connections with our jobs and
also appropriate outlets for grief and
so I'll be discussing all of these
throughout the presentation so now that
we all want to know what patch fatigue
is who's at risk of it kind of makes
sense that people whose job description
directly involves working with animals
would be at risk
so you know your veterinary staff and
animal care technicians and then of
course your research staff and your pis
but also your I cook staff and other
administrative staff they do have a risk
so if you think about how I cook
category II you know like protocol
review and if they're looking a lot of
category 8 protocols they still are
experiencing and thinking about animals
experiencing these protocols and so over
time that can lead to capacity as well
and even our just plain you know
administrative staff they're ordering
animals they hear about it they're
involved in the field so there's still a
risk for everyone despite their job
description requires them to actually
touch animals or not now the reports are
some risk factors which can predispose
people to developing compassion fatigue
so I'm just going to highlight a few of
them so people who were going to daily
basis with animals especially if you're
involved in a more long-term research
study that gives you more time to
develop bonds with your animals so that
increases risk for good procedures or
protocols people just may not feel
comfortable it's and may feel kind of a
dilemma and performing them sometimes
euthanasia would fall into this category
but also think about certain invasive
procedures like surgical models of
certain types or perhaps the idea of
using earth using death as an endpoint
so I especially think of researchers
themselves falling into that category
for procedures and support systems are
really important for us to have for
mental health that means that you have
people you can talk to that can kind of
provide you some compassion and care to
allow you to kind of refill your bank
and it's more difficult I think just a
handle emotional stress and trauma if
you feel like you're alone and of course
there's other risk factors very much
related to an individual's personality
and personal history
so like unresolved trauma previously or
really just an inability to communicate
maybe there needs to others those can
all you know hold into this so it's a
very you know
individual variations and how much
people are affected by this and I do
want to point out that the amount of
time and in this industry doesn't really
have any sort of effect on whether or
not you'll develop compassion fatigue so
people can be relatively new in the
field and get it quickly or you can have
been in the field for decades and not
have it so it's a lot of personal
variation so how can we try to determine
it for your suffering come from
compassion fatigue so there's some
different ways to categorize symptoms
but one way is to break them down into
these categories of intrusive arousal
and avoidance so our intrusive symptoms
are things like thoughts and images that
kind of are intrusive into your lives
they about the traumatic experience
these can manifest as things like
nightmares or just you know you're out
of work on the weekend but you're still
remembering and thinking about something
that you saw and it's going to lead to
an obsessive desire to actually help
certain animals and a healthy kind of
obsession with things and inability to
let go of work-related matters and
sometimes you can just start feeling
inadequate as a caregiver the arousal
symptoms these are things that are
changes in your emotional response so
increases in anxiety and frustration
anger and projection of anger onto
others sleep disturbances is really
common with this especially because
these emotional responses change you
physically and you can actually get not
only sleep disturbances but what's
called somatic illness which is where
you get physical effects of your stress
and so you can get sick easier you'll
have worsening of chronic diseases
potentially and then finally the
avoidance symptoms kind of as it sounds
you can get apathetic to things once
felt enjoyable that we're putting your
personal life and hobbies as well people
may start to feel like they only want to
put in the minimum at work when they
used to feel a lot more passionate about
doing more maybe not
feeling like they want to hang out with
their friends as much so they're
starting to isolate and this can
progress to even more destructive
behaviors like self medication and
addiction but you know not just with
drugs but things like online shopping
gambling those kind of things can worsen
or develop and then there's just another
way to categorize these symptoms by
instead mental physical and behavioral
changes so they're all basically what I
just mentioned but just categorize in a
different way so just you can see that
how they divided it up that way so James
Spillman she provides some retreats and
workshops for people that suffer from
fatigue mostly related to human um
healthcare industry but she had this
interesting trajectory of the
development of compassion fatigue in
five phases that I like so I'm just
going to quickly go over it where you
start out in the develop phase where
you're really idealistic or like keen
and committed to enthusiastic about work
as the compassion peak starts to set in
you get those emotional changes and
irritability having corners having or
oversights and mistakes at work and then
withdrawal so those are the avoidance
symptoms where you're starting to
isolate yourself from others not really
wanting to talk about work and
neglecting potentially people in their
personal lives as well and the zombie
phase is when you start putting yourself
on autopilot in a sense and this is
where more frustration anger sometimes
can lash out and the final result is
some sort of transformation that comes
from this so you can either undergo
what's called pathology and
victimization where you become
overwhelmed you kind of just continue in
this state and potentially just leave
the profession because you feel like
this is not for me I am obviously not
doing well here but the other
transformation you can have is a
positive change which is where you start
actually recognize these symptoms and
start to make changes in our lives and
using self-care strategies and manages
some of these underlying issues so when
we find ways to manage recognize our
stressors and our satisfiers and find a
balance in our chosen career that's what
I hope we can all come to
but now of course why should we care I
think hopefully most people would agree
with me that caring for the mental
well-being of people in our profession
is important no matter what but I think
that we usually draw into our profession
people that do deeply care about animals
and we really want to maintain them
because that's promotes better animal
welfare at the end you have those caring
people that walk that are committed and
enthusiastic and they're just going to
help drive our professions better and
better forward in advancements with
animal welfare so we want to keep them
in our field but if you want buy-in from
leadership for supporting mental health
initiatives and maybe you need a little
bit more than that so I also think we
should start framing this as a
occupational health issue actually and
it's other people agree with me so in
the current edition of the lab animal
medicine blue book actually you'll see
that in the occupational health chapter
they talked about psychosocial hazards
of what we do and they pretty much line
up with compassion fatigue so it talks
about how the human animal relationship
and research is complex and there can be
some kind of psychological dissonance
with the idea of we have animals as pets
maybe in her home versus animals that
object as objects at our work for use I
mean that can be difficult and it
mentions specific hazards like
desensitization to euthanasia or certain
procedures and how all of this leads to
anxiety and depression and of course all
of these psychosocial hazards are
related to compassion fatigue so I think
it's really important that we start
getting our occupational health programs
to be on board at our institutional
leadership to kind of recognize it as a
work hazard in our specific profession
and actively work to strategize at an
institutional level ways to combat it
now of course that's a very slow change
that can happen over time and I
No you know some occupational health
programs don't in my personal experience
don't feel like they're equipped to deal
with this which I understand if you
don't have a mental health professionals
in your occupational health program but
I think it's something that we need to
start talking about thinking about it
maybe this way so that over time we can
start utilizing occupational health
programs as a way to bring in compassion
fatigue strategies and also an
institution should care because if
employees are expecting compassion
fatigue there is an overall noticeable
increase noticeable effect on the
workforce so if you have a lot of
effective workers in your company you're
going to see decline in morale and
productivity so staff may not you know
complete assignments and texts or meet
deadlines on time as much you'll be
trends like higher absenteeism because
people are out sick more and they'll be
higher turnover rates I think that's a
pretty clear one that people see in our
field sometimes and actually there could
potentially be higher worker
compensation claims because with
decreased concentration and commitment
you can get higher levels of injury and
then decrease morale is a huge one
interdepartmental dysfunction goes along
with that your teams may not start
working together as well because people
are more irritated and frustrated and
quick to anger so and then the other
problem is if somebody new enters this
environment that's already having people
experience a lot of it even with a lot
of self-care it can be really difficult
to maintain a healthy mental state just
because of that kind of cycle that's
already happening and the place that
they enter so this isn't just a topic
for individuals to think about how do we
can help ourselves but also our company
to think about how it can help our
workforce to increase you know
productivity okay so what can we do
about it
and so of course there's many ways to
approach this and I hope that I and I'm
sure some of you who have some great
ideas I haven't even thought of but this
is kind of based on what I've done
and talk to other people about so I
think one step you can start to do is
send out a survey to your employees at
your institution and determine where
they think the biggest issues are and
their ideas for changes it can be made
on to improve their work environment now
we did not do this in Michigan when we
started kind of our comparative stuff
but I've talked to another a couple
other places that did this and I think
that it's really amazing because you may
be passionate about it but you don't
realize some things that somebody else
at a different apartment had ideas about
how to improve stuff so you can get a
lot of generate a lot of really ideas
and interest this way so I think that
was a really good idea but increasing
awareness and an education of the topic
is really important and that's kind of
how we started at Michigan when you
start talking about it and employees
start hearing about it it does create
over time a an environment that
normalizes people's emotional responses
to working with animals and encourages
them to express feelings free from shame
and embarrassment if they realize oh
it's okay that you can grieve over
animals in our work so the more time
more people talk about it I think people
realize it's okay to feel connect to
animals feel compassion and also then it
gives people a better chance of
recognizing these signs in themselves
I'm going to Sarah then start
determining strategies for coping on a
personal level so how you can start
increasing awareness very we started by
offering just a couple educational
lectures for our staff we made a general
announce about our all staff meeting
about it and then have some more
in-depth lectures than to attend and
they were similar to kind of the
beginning of this presentation in terms
of talking did a little bit more depth
about some signs and things like that
and that these were put together by me
and another technician so we're not
experts by any means but we became
potentially experts so I think anyone
even if they don't think that they can
do it if you have an interest in fashion
you can become axe
your institution and give a talk on this
and we also did have a counselor we came
in during this time to talk about
personal coping mechanisms and I'm going
to definitely circle back to counselors
later but we did include her during the
educational talk now another way we
implemented awareness is with just like
this poster I work through their office
of research communications to create and
distribute them into our animal
facilities and the goal is to
disseminate information not only to our
internal kind of animal care staff but
also to the wider research community
because all of them could be affected so
we want to be able to reach everybody as
much as possible so I'm just going to
look closer to contents it's pretty
simple poster we just wanted to have a
statement that emotional distress can
occur in this job and basically showing
that the university recognizes this can
happen and then we put a link to the
cost of caring brochure that's been put
out by a lass which is a really great
resource about human animal bond and
grief in our field and then finally we
put our information for universally
providing counseling services with all
also circle back to and I talk more
about counselors in the future but it's
information so it's easily accessible
for everybody I mentioned the cost of
caring brochure I just want to show it
here if you guys haven't heard about it
I recommend just look it up on the
website and download a copy of it it's
really great like very simple addresses
the human-animal bond in the field and
states that acknowledging feel our
feelings of animal care workers and
providing support and the workplace is
really important and I like the
statement that they have in there that
says if bereavement is addressed
appropriately individuals will feel
validated their coping mechanisms will
be strengthened and their ability to
sustain new bonds and form new bonds
will be reinforced so this is a great
resources why I included on the poster
because it kind of has a nice summary
it's easy you don't have to put it
together yourself so I encourage you all
to look that up now since all animal
users are at risk I think
that putting it in some in some
information about this in a required
training of some sort of a really good
stuff that everybody should go towards
have it either in an online training our
in-person training however your
institution does it I worked with our
training core that we have at Michigan
and put some language in our required
animal training for new users and I just
put a little snippet of it up there you
don't have to read that but where did a
section in our new user training called
the dilemma which really talked about
the ethical cost of using animals and
research in general so it was a perfect
spot to actually put in some information
about the emotional effect on humans as
well for and then also include the links
to the counseling services that are
available at the University and we do
have a required hands-on training for
our new rodent users which our trainers
started to just mention this as well
during that the in-person classes and
just bring it up so again where we
talked about it what more people start
recognizing that it's a thing especially
researchers you know graduate students
PhD students are the ones who usually
come to a left and those kind of
meetings where this is being talked
about more and more so I think it's
really important to try to reach that
population of animal users and another
option if you don't want to come up with
something yourself the ALS Learning
Library recently published this module
and I think it's great that the team
that put it together agree that it
should go into the occupational health
section of the training so that's where
you would find it and it's a really
pretty short one and it's a great
resource to start with even just for
yourself if you're interested in
learning more but also especially if
you're using Bayless Learning Library
for your required training for your
users already it's really easy to just
add that in as a module that they should
go through so I would really encourage
everybody to put something in required
user training either related to capacity
but even if you don't want to use that
terminology things like using words like
psychosocial hazards or talking just
about emotional costs of working with
research animals I think it's really an
easy way to bring awareness is put it in
some sort of required training there's
another way that you can kind of
evaluate compassion fatigue individually
and in your program is this online tool
that's out there and it's called the
professional quality of life scale and
it's available for free online it was
done by dr. Quigley and another
researcher the Karen Berg name of at the
moment the language in there is geared
more towards social worker type
professions but Catherine dogs if anyone
saw I think in 2014 she gave a talk at a
laughs about compassion fatigue and she
used this test and with the author's
permission changed the verbiage in the
questions more to geared towards animals
and she provided to that to me for free
and so you could contact her or you can
contact me I could get you never to the
test her name is Catherine thumb's um
and it's a pretty short test you can
hand it out to employees to do on their
own time to gauge their own quality to
their own level of compassion fatigue
and compassion satisfaction kind of
tests for both the way I used it was at
Michigan we just handed out at our
educational lectures for people to take
home you know do on their own time but
if you wanted to use it as an anonymous
survey you could ask people to fill it
out and then you know not know names so
there's no association with anybody
particularly and then you can kind of
have a sense of how it is at your
university what the percent of affected
people are or institution I said
University but obviously ioan's of the
university sorry
so once you've started to bring
awareness to what compassion fatigue is
what are the next steps that an
institution can take to prevent combated
so personal coping mechanisms are an
essential part of management work stress
burnout and passion fatigue which
includes things like self-care and
mindfulness and depending on where you
work you actually may already have a
bunch of resources available to you for
this accurate medical school there
actually can be resources
hospital staff regarding capacity that
are already there and available for you
our institution has a really great HR
program that provides individual and
department kind of style workshops and
lectures on things like reducing stress
mindfulness stuff like that so those are
great that you can utilize the trains
counselors already for and so I talked
about how we had a counselor come in and
speak during our kind of initial
education lectures on self-care topics
and we reached out to our counseling
program and this is something really
important that I think I want to stress
this whenever you're going to utilize
the counselor it's important to reach
out to them first and talk to them about
animal research the realities of what we
do you know and make sure that they're
comfortable with it because the worst
thing you can do is bring someone in who
has a negative opinion and you can risk
traumatizing people worse depending on
the reaction you know the counselor so
make sure that they're you know they
have accurate information about what
your department does I mean it's okay
you know in our counselor said like
ethically a counselor has to declare you
know if you say hey what's your feelings
on animal research because this is what
we want you to talk about they have to
tell you if they you know argument Lee
against it because that would be a
comically conflict for them to be
involved with that so I think that's
really important to remember and just
look at their resources what I want to
stress look into resources you might
already have especially like luckily a
Michigan or a big University we have
these resources available already for us
to start you know actually tapping
however you know I think there's any
reason you couldn't reach out to an
external counseling service and as long
as you find someone who's comfortable an
animal research is willing to come in
you can utilize the expert that way but
also there are I found to research
specific animal research specific
consulting services that will travel to
your University and do compassion
fatigue seminars and workshops as well
so these are people that are you know
obviously know about our field and are
involved in it okay so mental health
professionals say
at the cornerstone of the prevention of
compassion fatigue is actually good
self-care and so these are some of the
kind of stuff we talked about with our
counselor I want you talk to this
I'm obviously you could go into huge
depth into this topic I'm not going to
but I just want to show that I'm not a
another expert on this matter but you
can find information out there and give
it to your employees you know and talk
about it if you're willing even if
you're not an expert you know self-care
techniques aren't important to just
bring up and mention so I just going to
go over some of these really important
ones like joke very generally so I think
everybody knows that getting enough
sleep is really important and not any
other sleep makes you vulnerable to
stress and compounds physical ailments
so this is all going to affect our
compassion fatigue levels exercise may
be one of the more overlooked types of
self-care because it's actually been
shown the exercise just mild you know
exercise can help combat feelings of
depression and chronic health problems
I'm still thinking about maybe doing
something with a group like with making
a walking room for lunch at your
institution or something like that you
can even make it more you know instead
of just by yourself you can involve a
group of employees and things like that
proper eating and drinking so you have
more energy to deal with stress so
finding your time finding time yourself
every day is really essential for your
mental well-being and going along with
this is finding ways to recharge your
energy which may be things I mentioned
like exercise or meditation or yoga but
really just the most important thing I
want you all to be aware of is that
making yourself a priority and setting
some self-care goals that will work for
you it's really important and I really
like the bad analogy so I put it in here
because the way that our counselor
described why self-care is important in
relation to compassion Teague and stress
is that everyone's it's the water bottle
metaphor so imagine your stress and
trauma kind of levels like a water
bottle and everyone's ability to manage
it in our lives is different so everyone
have a different
sighs water bottle just naturally and
we'll fill it up and we can handle our
stress levels until at some point it's
going to overflow you're going to hit
your tipping point and this leads to
those manifestations all the signs of
compassion fatigue that we've talked
about you know like changes in emotional
responses is out first trouble sleeping
but if we can decrease the flow of water
that's great but that's not always
possible right you can't always prevent
the stresses and things in your job you
can't change things so in order to
continue handling the flow coming at you
you have to find ways to poke holes in
the water model kind of to allow you to
handle that amount that's coming in and
these holes are basically those little
self-care things that you provide and
you do and so I just think that's a
really nice analogy I want to show that
with you it's something that is also a
really good idea is to have some sort of
transition from your work to your home I
flipped this picture because I think the
analogy is more turning from Superman at
work back into Clark Kent at home
instead of the other way around so for
those of us who have people at home like
family or pets or just roommates
sometimes as soon as you walk in the
door from work here have to start caring
for a whole new set of people or animals
so since our jobs a lot of times require
actively caring for other people during
the day or thinking about living
creatures during the day it can be
really draining to go directly from one
to the next without stopping to give
yourself sometimes this is talking about
that knee time not recharged and renewal
so I think it's important to have a
transition period between the two and
carve that out for yourself you could
you know just stay in the car when you
get home for 10 minutes and listen to an
audio book that you wanted to listen to
or whatever and then another thing you
could do is or kind of a symbolic way to
put away the day is transition out of
your work clothes into your a different
set of clothes as soon as you get home
and you're in your me space now and try
to just divide yourself from your work
more actively and also if you have to do
work at home try to set a specific area
for your professional work stuff
from their stairs in the home to kind of
continue making those symbolic
separations which can help your mind
separate them as well and as the nature
of our work can cause us to sometimes do
things that we consider unpleasant it's
essential that you determine if there's
any things that you find especially
distressing and you would consider off
limits and draw the line for yourself
and that could be certain species that
you can't work with certain types of
procedures or protocols you don't want
to work with and obviously when you're
applying for a job you could look for a
position that meets those requirements
so you could continue work in the field
that you want to work in while
minimizing what's traumatic specifically
to you now in a current job that you're
in you may have some flexibility to
allow you to decide that line but not
always you know obviously understand
this is something you would hopefully do
but it's not always possible then I just
I want to bring that up for people that
are supervisors or managers think about
that with your employees if you have the
ability to help them be flexible if they
come to you and kind of be open to
listening to them or recognizing when
there's something maybe stressful and
there's a way that you can do things
like work sharing or you know commit it
especially just communicating with them
so I think something really important is
communicating about animal endpoints and
giving people the the opportunity to be
present or not present for maybe an end
point for an animal especially a one
that they've formed a bond with don't
just assume for them that they may not
want to be there because it's just
stressful maybe they need that to stay
closure or they want to be the person
that's there because that allows people
to help form their own coping mechanisms
for things that we do that can be
traumatic so I think it's important
especially for supervisors and managers
to consider how much you communicate
with your employees about things like
that and just being flexible as you can
obviously it's not always possible now I
mentioned before about support systems
and that is really important as a coping
mechanism and something that we can
actively
to do in our job so something that's
really unique in our field I would say
is a lack of social support we get from
what we do so I think everybody's pretty
aware animal research can be a
controversial topic and I'm sure many of
you have actually experienced negative
reactions when you tell people what you
do and sometimes that means you don't
tell people what you do I've had that
exact experience myself so and because
of that then you're less likely to share
with others may be something that is
traumatic to you and so we don't talk
about it and um you know I like to think
about like this if a firefighter has
experienced something really traumatic
you know helping somebody you know and
they had a traumatic experience they can
talk about it with somebody in the
community and they are feeling like a
hero that's how they're viewed it so
they get that support from the society
saying you know your hero your job is
amazing you know what you've done and so
it helps them re-energize it does help
how that external support but we have
the industry potentially don't have that
now this leads into a whole topic about
transparency in our industry and how we
can work to actually grow I think a
better social support system with
through openness and transparency and
there's definitely some talks just
coming up recently about this topic
exactly if you're interested in that the
Americans for medical progress
organization is something really great
to look into obviously that's not what
this topic topic is about or this talk
but I think that it's something that we
can actually work as a as a field to
actually kind of grow a better social
support network by being open about what
we do and I'm sharing the amazingness of
biomedical research everybody
understands so friends and family I next
have a talk about friends and family yet
so in that same vein because they um
friends and family may not understand
what we do or you know you don't want to
share with them what you do you they may
not be the best support system for
specifically for compassion fatigue in
our field they may be you know but if
you don't
friends and family um you may need a
different kind of support group
available for you so I discussed
counselors and I want to talk about how
you selected counselors are so if your
institution has internal counseling
support available I think number one
it's essential to make sure your
employees know about it because I found
that a lot of people myself included
didn't really realize that we have a
support system with free counseling
available for people that work at our
University and so and a lot of our
animal technicians didn't know about
that either so we learned with our
counselor at the service to make some
informational cards to put into our
staff break rooms and this is the front
of the card that she put together with a
little quote from a Merck Research
Laboratory memorial service that they
had which is really nice and then on the
back information on the Employee
Assistance Program so making sure people
are aware of the resources that are
already there is really important and
then something I am also especially per
fondant that we can do in our industry
is a peer support group so we started
one of these at our at Michigan that
occurs once a month and the meetings are
a time for people to come in and discuss
specific issues you know for others to
offer support suggestions to each other
really you can structure these some kind
of support groups however works best for
your place of work and me and another
technician Kayleigh Bennett she and I
you know became the facilitators of the
group we didn't you know lead it per se
but we found that the biggest thing that
we had to do as facilitators was to try
to keep people on topic and prevent it
from becoming just an unhealthy rant
session because there's that tipping
point between trying to be helpful when
people are sharing about problems versus
just you know venting about the job
until it becomes a circle of everybody's
venting and then now you've made a
negative emotional experience and so you
can I have to try to hold that balance
oh okay well let's try to give some
positive feedback or you know support
and then with something that I really
like that we did with people
Kame we would ask them to come up with a
self-care goal for themselves and then
check in throughout the meetings and
give it code each other accountability
so that you can't just say oh I should
do that and then you never make any
changes because everybody does that so
it's kind of nice to say okay this is
what I want to do and then next time
maybe you didn't do any of it so we can
ask you what can is there a way we can
help you motivate you so I think that
that was really important so I think
this next topic here employee engagement
is one of the most important for
preventing compassion fatigue which is
really connecting with the purpose of
why we do what we do so when someone can
connect with the difference that they're
making in the world because of their job
it can help them understand how
important they are which really helps
with employee engagement and job
satisfaction
so people really need sometimes help
remembering what drove them to enter the
skill in the first place
now although many on the animal care
side are not directly involved in the
research they're obviously we know an
essential part of the process and
sometimes people need to be reminded of
that especially by connecting them with
the research outcomes of the research
you know they did help I Ground Zero
basically helped happen in this sense of
purpose increases morale and retention
of workers and we know of course animals
are greatly benefited by having a caring
and compassionate worker force so we
need to keep these people in our field
engaged in our field now the human
animal bond is what connects us males we
work with and I I want to make sure it's
clear that like some people would say
that if somebody's experiencing a patch
of fatigue that maybe they just you know
shouldn't like work with animals but I
think that we need to encourage the
human animal bond because it's important
to form bonds with the animals we work
with because that's why they have such
compare it's our emotional investment in
the animals that we care for that
propelled us to advocate and work for
their well-being
so you have to find a way to strike the
balance between being emotionally
invested but not so emotionally attached
and that's very hard balance to strike
but I think and obviously that you know
something they talking to a counselor
might help in an individual way but I
think self-care techniques as in
connecting with the purpose of doing
what we do allows people to kind of
continue to review those emotional
resources and allow them to form bonds
over and over and continue having that
caring passionate compassion for animals
over decades of time so talking about
connecting employees with the research
side of things there's ways that you can
do this for instance we have a program
where we have research seminars with
investigators coming in to talk to our
husbandry staff and share their work so
that way we can bridge that divide that
sometimes happens especially in a huge
institution like Michigan between
researchers and husbandry staff and this
way employees can hear those specifics
about amazing outcomes of research
that's happened directly with animals
they may have been changing cages for
and I think that that really helps um
bridge that divide and another more
passive way you can do it instead of an
active seminar is through newsletters so
we have a monthly Animal Care and Use
Program newsletter which has research
spotlights every time with amazing
research that's come out of Michigan so
you can read about for instance here why
especially bred rats that you know maybe
somebody was like oh I change cages for
this lab you know these you know these
animals led to increased knowledge about
the connection between us exercise and
under its capacity and card effects so I
think newsletters are really great oh
how else can we keep boys engaged in our
field something that I think maybe
sometimes is overlooked is actually
empowering employees to be involved in
decision making especially those that I
may feel on the animal husbandry side
when they're you know lower down
authoritative totem-pole they feel like
they don't have any input into decisions
being made about animals at work so we
have an animal enrichment committee at
Michigan that I think is a great way
that we empower our employees we invite
everyone from all over the department
participates it doesn't matter if you
are an administrative staff or a company
worker anybody can come and this
committee was started very small you
know not less than a decade ago and it
has grown to be basically a very
essential part of our animal care
program and generates ideas that we can
investigate and you know a validate and
test and implement and there will be a
talk I don't actually know if it's
already happened I hope not but Jenny
Jones our an animal enrichment
coordinator is going to speak about this
in depth today I'm not going to dwell on
it too much I just want to bring up as a
possibility of I think it's really good
to actually come back and Pacioretty to
think about these kind of engagement and
just a few things that the Amishman
committee is actually done in terms of
not only the people that are on the
committee themselves but even the wider
community they engage employees and
researchers to do stuff like recycling
glove boxes for our rabbits and rodents
and just milk jugs for our pigs so that
people can feel like they're actually
directly contributing to Richmond
programming is that it even if they
don't come sit on the committee and then
they've also done really amazing things
like fundraising in order to have money
targeted specifically for the enrichment
committee for the Richmond program and
then you know I've talked about
administrative staff something that was
pretty amazing idea I thought was this
farm-to-table herb garden program where
admin staff could grow herbs on their
desks that they would harvest and
actually feed as enrichment to some of
our animals and so that was a way to
have people feel like a positive
connection to the animals that they're
working around and form and never even
see I think was really nice program and
then something really important is our
subcommittees on certain special topics
that
have formed to take on a more
complicated issue which gives some
technicians opportunities to take lead
on various issues to talk about that
empowerment it allows people to grow and
you know because of one of our
technicians Sarah Thurston who's also
talking to super passionate about our
about pair housing rabbits now she is
pretty much an expert and the lead on
our and created a actual position for
her for rabbits social housing here so
you know it is a great way to empower
employees to even grow in their own
careers as well and allows our
technicians to feel kind of that renewed
sense of purpose and also better our
field and then the last topic I'm the
missed guest today is the use of animal
tributes or memorial events to help us
remember animals that we've used in
research and thank them for the
contribution and this is kind of where I
talk about like those outlets for
appropriate for grief so it gives people
on the way you know a safe space to
share stories and you know actually
grieve and talk about their emotions and
this is a great way to validate
normalize feelings for those that do
experience it and can then therefore
come back compassion fatigue and the
tributes
excuse me can be actual services or you
can dedicate maybe like a statue or a
plaque or a garden space or whatever you
choose to do actually there's been quite
a few places that have been doing the
more elements for decades successfully
and I encourage you to look up this 2002
Euler article by Susan elif about this
subject called
the fourth edition alarm remembering the
animals and so you can see here this is
a list that comes from this article that
just talks about some of the places that
have been doing these events already and
I know other institutions have recently
implemented some of these kind of events
and I know one for instance was able to
get a patient to come speak at their
event to talk about how their life was
saved due to medical advancements
because no research so that direct pace
you know from bench to bedside
a connection so I think that was a great
way to connect everyone who attended
with the purpose of what we're doing so
if you can have some kind of connection
like that I would be really great this
is an example of Susan had in her
article which was about this Korean Food
and Drug Administration actually has a
pagoda outside of it on the grounds of
their main facility in Seoul and every
year they have an animal ceremony
daughter analyze the animals I think
they started 1983 doing that so this is
just a nice little plaque that basically
our pagoda but or you could do like a
plaque like that actually the first
known commemorative activity in North
America that focused on animals was held
in well the University of Guelph in 1993
and I just wanted to read a little quote
from the text that they said at that
event because I really I really liked it
I love this I like the sentiment that it
has and it says we are causing animals
to be born causing them to live through
a variety of unusual experiences and
causing them to die this is a form of
power that cannot be taken lightly today
is an opportunity to acknowledge the
animals role in what we do to
acknowledge that without them our
research and teaching would be
fundamentally altered to think the
animals seems logically inappropriate
because their contribution was taken not
given yet we are grateful for and even
dependent upon their role I just think
that that is a really interesting way to
frame my own feelings on the use of
animals in research and I think it's
really important to acknowledge and
thank them for their role and what we do
at Michigan something that we've been
doing in the kind of memorial sense is
using these memory boards so for the
past two years we've been doing a
science of enrichment symposium and
we've provided cards for people to share
stories just names or a picture of an
animal that they would like to honor and
then we display them which has really
I've been very well received we've also
given out paper feed hearts for people
to write a name on and take home and
plant in their own garden for to create
maybe a mole
garden and this year's enrichment
suppose iam were hoping actually
provides some flower bulbs for people to
take home and plant we also use these
memory cards we have a different version
of them that we put at our department
booth for a no annual university-wide
research fair so this was allowing
anyone who came by the booth so you know
people that actually worked with our
department but also researchers from all
over campus could come by and contribute
a card and then we would display those
throughout the day so I was a great way
doll so try to involve our research
staff in this our we have a compassion
fatigue committee you Michigan and we've
started to work to develop our own
official memorial event which we would
like to frame as a celebration more than
a memorial I like that idea that we
would use it to highlight research
accomplishments that have come out of
the University of Michigan over the last
year and then also talk about
advancements for our animals themselves
so things that about our like rabbits
social housing and dogs social housing
programs now funding such an event can
be difficult we are hoping to partner
with our larger larger opps research to
utilize funds and therefore make it not
just an internal departmental style
event but actually it have been open to
the entire research community and again
trying to reach not just our own our own
field but researchers outside as well
and some other ideas that have come out
of it
you know we may or may not be able to do
but I think it's good to talk to other
people have these ideas you know having
some sort of art dedicated that is
either made we even talked about having
animals make the art like if we could
get non-toxic paint and have the animals
walk across paper and then make that
kind of art that you could display and
dedicate or if you have outside space
potential you could secure a little spot
of it you could plant a tree or for the
plaque there have a place for maybe
specifically for quiet reflection time
so overall I think that a memorial
ceremonies are really wonderful way
to keep employees engaged in their job
and create this culture of openness and
discuss the idea of compassion fatigue
in the human-animal bond and function of
coping strategy so to conclude today I
have shared ideas to try to combat
compassion fatigue in our industry I
believe we must first make sure that
there's an awareness of the topic and
then provide resources regarding
individual coping mechanisms and
consider how we can provide support
systems to others especially if people
don't have external support systems as
well we really need to work on engaging
employees to promote increased job
satisfaction helping them remember the
importance of why we do what we do and
then provide some sort of memorial
activity or tribute or celebration even
as an opportunity to express grief and I
hope some of you may be inspired today
to implement some changes at your own
institution and be the change that I
believe our profession meet so I just
want to thank everyone for their time
and attention today and you are free to
contact me
we'll do some a couple questions right
now and you can contact me with any
other questions if I can't get to them I
wanted to put some acknowledgments up
here people at the University of
Michigan that I worked with Kayleigh
Bennett Jennifer Jones
Jenny Lofgren and Sarah thirst have all
been involved with the capacity stuff
there and Sarah's there since taking
over as our compassion fatigue committee
chairman as I'll be leaving my residency
in the next six months and then I also
wanted to put up two people that I met
at the universe at a last just last year
Preston who is going to be doing in a
last webinar on compassion fatigue and
and under on a Pavan from Ohio so
they've been implementing some things
and they have their great resources as
well for doing capacity stuff so I would
encourage you to if you know them to
talk to them or reach out to them so yes
thank you very much and we'll do
questioning now I believe me yes and
thank you Marion for the informative
present
Asian and inspiring work and culture
you've created in your lab we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button I'll answer as
many questions as we have time for so
let's take a look at the questions
already coming in from our audience
members our first question for him is
what was the biggest hurdle you
encountered getting started a great
question so I think the biggest thing
specifically at Michigan was for a huge
institution and you know with a lot of
employees and we were going through a
lot of change when I was trying to start
up something and a lot of people were
experiencing work burnout just
overworked and so that was difficult to
get people to actually even care because
there was like I am overworked I don't
have time to try to come to some lecture
or do a peer support group they don't
have time in their day so that was that
was definitely difficult and I think it
was just a lot of persistence on the
part of me and Kaylee to say we really
want to change the culture here and so
it may be a kind of slow going but just
kind of slowly being like okay we'll
just keep offering to peer support
groups and keep you know bringing it
putting it on our you know employee
newsletter so that everybody knows it
still happens when we started to get
more people interested in attending so
that definitely was a big hurdle on
getting people to realize that they
should care about it as well then when I
also think our audience members for
their questions today we have a few more
here and any questions that aren't
answered today will be emailed to you in
the future
our next question what are some
resources that you recommend to learn
more about compassion fatigue great
question so
I actually do have here a couple more
slides that I didn't show you right here
at the end um with some resources so I
think that the I did mention of course a
last Learning Library so I'd recommend
for sure looking at kibosh critique
module also the American Veterinary
Medical Association as you know
recognizing of course in our kind of
general practitioner veterinary side
that this is a big problem so they have
a whole webpage and so if you google and
look for the working compassion fatigue
page on ABMA they have a lot of great
resources about it so i'd mentioned
Katherine Dodds she's the one who had
changed the professional quality like
scale
wording so she has a website as well
that Katharine Docks com+ she has some
great resources on compassion fatigue
and you know she came in spoken a lot so
even though some of them are more geared
towards general veterinary medicine you
know she obviously understands our field
and then there's the compassion fatigue
awareness project which also has some
great resources on the kind of compiled
at all the website there if you're
interested and then I did mention the
consulting services before and I did put
up their information here so I met the
lady next I'm ok Kaiser from coke plus a
last she was there and she has created
this counseling kind of consulting
service specifically for people in the
animal research field and so she I know
worked with Preston at the University of
Washington doing it a kind of a needs
assessment with them so they're great
she's a great resource to reach out I
know Preston really like working with
her and then the animal research
consulting company animal research
consulting comm I just found online that
they offer workshops and like seminars
they'll come in and talk about
compassion fatigue specifically so those
are the two kind of consulting services
that if you want to reach out to an
outside expert they're really great to
go to thank you
we have time for one more question
what's one piece of advice for someone
who wants to start compassion fatigue
initiatives at their own institution
alright great great and it's question I
would say the biggest thing is trying to
get you know more than just yourself
because you want to have a sustainable
program so you don't want it to rest on
just the shoulders of one person who may
be leaving for three years from the red
you know the residents you've done you
want to make sure that there's a group
of people that can you know be
interested in this
so finding some interested people and
forming a committee so that you can you
know help each other and make sure that
I think it's really important is to try
to make sure that there's people from a
lot of different places within the
institution so you know having from the
veterinary side the business office side
you know your husband.you technicians or
your trainers and that will give you a
lot of different perspectives that I
think are really important to kind of
craft a program that'll mean a lot of
different needs is it getting a lot of
those perspectives of how is this you
know what kind of things would be most
beneficial for husbandry obviously may
not be the same for veterinary staff so
I think that that's a really good thing
it you know to do is reach out and find
people that you can kind of coerce into
saying hey this is really important
let's let's meet about this so that you
also have that accountability to and you
know Drive to go together if everybody's
like interested because if it's just one
person it can get overwhelming and
harvest are things and you may feel like
oh I can't do this but and then
obviously I mean you'll answer one piece
of advice but I would say you know reach
out to people at other institutions -
you're not alone if you want to start
this obviously you can ask me you can
ask Preston there's so many people out
there that have started these
compassionate initiatives from nothing
to making it something so you can do it
but you can always reach out to other
people that have done it before or
advice and just support to feel like it
you know it can be so going and it you
can feel you know you can feel
discouraged
times sometimes but I think it's so
important that we need to keep talking
about this in our field oh yeah
well thank you and I want to thank you
again for this presentation would you
like to provide any closing remarks for
our attendees today before we close Dion
I guess I just like to say well thank
you all for you know sitting here
listening to this and I hope that you
learned something and I really hope that
it did inspire you that you know this is
something that we need to start
considering more and more that you know
we need to care about the mental
well-being of you know ourselves in this
profession because as I said obviously
throughout this that having people that
remain positively engaged and can
continue forming bonds and feel
compassion that obviously is only going
to help increase the animal welfare
because you're having more people that
are you know wanting to promote animal
welfare and keep those people in our
field I think it's really important that
we don't lose those people that are so
passionate about it because they get
overwhelmed with the emotions that maybe
they didn't expect to experience because
nobody told them and then they felt like
they they're wrong or it's abnormal like
no will nobody else is feeling this
maybe this is weird and maybe I
shouldn't be in this field because you
know nobody talks about it but you know
and I personally have experienced that
in the beginning of this field that
people didn't talk about it so I think
that's important is to say hey oh it's
okay you know you're feeling grief
because that animal was euthanized
that's okay but you know so just
continue talking about this and I hope
that all of you will talk about this at
your own institution if you don't
already
and I want to thank labrum a key today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2018
they'll receive an email from Laverton
oh when this webcast will be available
for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who me
and miss today's live event that's all
for now
thanks for joining us we hope to see you
again soon buh-bye